once in venice there were 6,000 looms
that said velvet we are
the last i
am alberto bevilacqua i am
the managing director and ceo of
luigi bevilacqua it seems that the
bevilacqua family has been in the field of
weaving since 1400
there is a testimony in  to this effect a
painting by a Venetian painter giovanni
meek conserved where on a cartouche
of this painting we refer to the
weaver giacomo bevilacqua
we produce velvets in the same
way in which they were produced three or
four centuries ago
the white house of the kremlin in quirinale
la casa rosada  homes have been furnished
and very prestigious with our
fabrics in today's world and people
want things produced in a short time
so they must be
industrially produced and therefore the craftsman
tends to disappear a bit
clearly the craftsmanship
costs a lot of  more
logically, however, both a product that both
visually and manually is of a
higher quality than
we are  or practically alone in Italy
it is absolutely important for us to carry
on this tradition to continue the
tradition of our ancestors
this art that otherwise
has been practically lost all over the world